so
i'd like to
introduce panayotis martikopoulos
who's a professor uh
a researcher at cnrs and
university of grenoble and critical labs
and is connected to death
from some prestigious university in
europe with a very beautiful
library
when i had to take it away
thanks cos they actually as i recently
learned this is
the beautiful library that you see is
montreal so not europe but uh yeah
uh
anyway uh thanks a lot uh thanks a lot
for the introduction thanks a lot for
inviting me and for putting together
this very exciting workshop
and uh
of course as you may have noticed uh
there has been a change of uh of uh
schedules since ship was supposed to uh
speak
uh right now but uh for uh for me it was
actually quite serendipitous because uh
the what i want to talk about today uh
uh dovetails uh quite well with
uh the previous talk by manolis uh
because i also want to explore um in
this talk the limits of uh min max
optimization algorithms not from the
point of view of complexity theory but
from the point of view of dynamical
systems
and uh it's not so much that we're
trying to i don't want to
uh establish a lower uh complexity
bounds like in manuel stock uh what i
want to do is i want to examine some of
the standard algorithms that we use in
practice and to see what kind of uh
behavior uh emerges in the low ground
what are their asymptotic convergence
properties and all that
um so
uh
since i'm not i'm lucky enough not to be
in the first day of the
workshop i will just skip everything
that has to do with motivation why we're
interested in min max optimizations if
you're in the room you probably know why
you're interested
and i'll go directly into one of the
most popular playgrounds that we've uh
that we're using to test
our algorithms and to develop new ones
and this is a figure that you've
probably seen at least a couple of times
i'm pretty sure we'll see it at least
three or four times until this workshop
is over and has to do with uh this very
simple uh min max optimization problem
uh
uh min max xy x1 x2 here uh and the
the
um and the standard gradient descent
descent algorithm vanilla gradient
algorithm and the way that it diverges
which is something that also uh yangchai
uh uh spoke about uh talked about
yesterday the reason being that when you
do a gradient descent
on this very simple uh problem
uh
you are always taking a step along the
um along the tangent which then forces
you to spiral outwards
and uh as young
also uh
explained
this was also this is uh
the birthplace uh this was the
birthplace of uh of other algorithms
like extra grading the extra gradient
algorithm
and
the uh and the pop-offs version uh which
is uh nowadays called the optimistic
gradient algorithm which uh take an
extra step or they interpolate this
extra gradient step from previous
observations and so managed to change
this um this divergent landscape that we
have for a grading descent ascent into a
very nice uh convergence inward uh
spiral and convergent sequence all right
so
uh
all this all this is something uh all
these are things that you've uh uh that
you've seen uh many times over nothing
new here
uh what i want to say is that uh it is
precisely of this huge disparity in the
behavior of a standard gradient descent
ascent algorithm and
it's extra gradient or optimistic
grading versions that uh we've been
using this very simple min max uh
problem this uh
and more generally all the bi-linear uh
the setting of bi-linear min max
optimization problems basically as a
testing ground to uh for new algorithms
so
whenever there is an algorithmic idea we
try at least it is quite common to try
it out on this game
see how it improves behavior and then
expand on this uh build on uh on any
improvement uh
improvements that are observed and
hopefully get better and
better performance guarantees in more
general problems than simply bilinear
games
so
um
what i want to start um
discussing is what happens if we are in
a more
ml oriented setting where we don't have
access to uh perfect gradients when we
start uh
using stochastic gradients and we only
have access to the gradient uh field of
the uh of our min max objective via a
stochastic first order oracle all right
so in this case if we just take the very
same algorithms then these very uh nice
dichotomy between
the divergence of standard vanilla
gradient algorithms and the convergence
of their extra gradient siblings
breaks down and
in fact
okay so i say that slide doesn't change
for some reason
okay
right okay so that's the right slide
so uh as i was saying if you if you only
have access to uh stochastic stochastic
uh first order oracle then
uh the behavior of uh these three
algorithms now becomes very difficult to
tell apart uh
and i uh claim that you know if you're
looking at these or these or this uh uh
image it is basically impossible to tell
whether one has been generated by an
extra gradient or a gradient uh standard
gradient algorithm
and
there have been uh significant efforts
to correct this uh
failure of convergence in the stochastic
setting
uh either by uh via iterate averaging so
instead of looking at the last iterator
of the method to uh look at
an appropriate ergodic or time average
or cost coverage
uh this is uh this is sometimes referred
to in the literature as a polia cooper's
averaging and uh
it is
very uh very successful in the realm of
convex concave problems
but uh if we are beyond this uh if we're
beyond this regime and we're really
interested in the convergence of the
last iterate of the of the method then
we need some some mechanism with which
to mitigate the noise that enters that
enters the process
and for these are either either uh
approaches based on variance reduction
uh tatiana chavdarob and here authors
have
a very nice paper in eurips uh
describing exactly that
or uh you can find a sort of fine tune
the algorithms a little bit and
play with the step sizes and introduce
for instance a double step size uh
variant of extra gradient where you have
a different step size for controlling
the step with which you explore the
landscape the min max landscape and the
different much smaller uh step size with
which you are actually updating the base
state of the algorithm and if you uh if
you control the two appropriately if you
explore much more aggressively than you
update
uh then uh you get
again uh even in the stochastic case
a convergent
a convergence result for the methods
last
last iterate
right
so um
to sum up uh what i want to say so far
is that in the deterministic case we
have this uh very important i call it a
very significant dichotom between
convergent and non-convergent uh first
order methods which is
lost in the stochastic case unless we do
some very special uh tricks to somehow
uh recover it
and the reason i'm calling these tricks
uh somehow special is that this image
that i described is actually uh
extremely fragile uh what i mean by that
that if we take this original uh uh
first of all uh if we take this original
bi-linear game and we perturb it a
little bit and we go a bit beyond the
bilinear case and this is something that
we would like to do because uh at least
in ml we would
like to apply these algorithms and these
methods
to uh problems that are in no way shape
or form convex concave
so if we do this if we take just the
original min max bilinear min max
problem and we add a very small and
epsilonic perturbation
then the entire landscape that i
described before are collapses and what
happens is that instead of
of even in the deterministic case
instead of having this uh
difference between the divergent
gradient method and the con the
convergent extra gradient or
or optimistic gradient or double step
size extra gradient or what have you
extra gradient method here by the if you
just consider a slightly perturbed game
then
all convergence bets are off
and all these algorithms you can show
that they actually converge to uh to an
attracting limit cycle which is sort of
a universal trap for all these
algorithms
and uh
something which is significant is that
in contrast to uh the
the bilinear case where there was also a
sharp distinction between deterministic
and stochastic and the stochastic regime
here
in the uh when we are outside of this
bilinear sandbox
uh the difference between deterministic
and stochastic
algorithms is much less pronounced so
if you take the same algorithms and you
apply them to the same game
but you just have access to stochastic
gradients not deterministic gradients
then you see this the same long-term
behavior uh in the limit of course uh
in both the deterministic and stochastic
case namely all of these algorithms
converge spiral
with some fluctuations of course due to
the noise to the same limit site
all right
and
so if i were to sum up again here you
see that when we're out of the bilinear
world in fact when we're out of the
monotone world uh we no longer have this
uh this fine distinction where uh more
sophisticated uh first order methods
might lead to better or different
outcomes and this even for arbitrarily
small perturbations of our original min
max
objective
and also that it turns out that
stochasticity plays here a much less
important role than it does in the
context of
of
bilinear min max games
which should not be interpreted that
in the sense that stochastic somehow uh
becomes benign and uh decides to help us
in the uh in the non-monotone regime no
it is just that the uh deterministic uh
uh uh the deterministic framework
becomes more difficult and this is this
difficulty
these inherent difficulties for on
non-monotone min max optimization
problems that i want to discuss and to
try to understand why uh this landscape
why do all these uh uh phenomena uh
occur and uh whether we can somehow uh
systematize their uh their study
and uh uh so if i were to uh stop with
the um before jumping into the details
of the talk uh then the overall
objective would be to understand
precisely what is the long run behavior
of first order methods in non-linear
non-monotone min-max games
and
just as manolis was saying
in the talk right before
i want to explore
the gulf between minimization problems
where these same first order algorithms
are known to converge
to components of critical points and to
also avoid saddle points in one way or
another
and i would like to examine the same
type of questions in the context of min
max optimization namely whether uh to
see whether grading methods always
whether it is possible for grading
methods to always converge to critical
points and what are the possible limit
sets that might arise uh in this context
and uh i should of course say that this
is uh not just um uh um this
has
this talk will actually contain um a
range of results uh from
uh
from some
from a number of papers uh where the
unifying viewpoint is exactly uh that of
the theory of dynamical systems uh which
will allow us to uh go from this script
continuous time and then
and back again and study continuous time
dynamical systems and then build a
dictionary with which we can uh
regain
some sort of some semblance of
convergence uh in the discrete time
setting
um
so yeah of course
this as i was saying this was not uh
this has been uh a
research thread that we've been pursuing
with uh a number of uh colleagues from
uh from switzerland france and uh and
the states and singapore so george and
uh so let me
jump right into the actual uh theory and
the actual map
and uh
i can't
i can't stress enough that i want this
to be
as
open-ended as possible so please if you
have any uh any sort of questions or you
want to throw any sort of stones this is
what this slider is designed for so
please don't hesitate
all right
yeah
probably
that will be sure about the model uh
until now all the noise that you
described about the position even for
the positive results in the mid max
bilinear case what are the
characteristics of noise even roughly
weight two slides because i haven't
discussed
that was all background all right so
so uh exactly so
uh
two uh two problems uh
we will discuss uh minimization problems
min max problems uh for most of the talk
i will be assuming uh i will be assuming
that our uh feasible region our domain
our state space is uh the entire uh all
of our d
this is basically just to simplify the
presentation
most of what i'm gonna i'm going to say
also holds for the constrained setting
uh but some of the statements are a bit
more
complicated to state but to write down
not conceptually so for most of the talk
uh things will be unconstrained
and as for the uh
blanket assumptions for uh for our for
the type of objectives that we will
consider
we will consider both uh deterministic
ones but also stochastic ones which are
the expectations of some uh random
function uh
uh defined over some complete
probability space
the uh
the main difficulties here is we as i
said we're not going to be assuming any
convex structure for the function which
means that also that uh f is difficult
to manipulate in closed form so uh
everything will be in the black box
setting no white box results like in the
previous store
and
we will focus throughout on
finding uh critical points so critical
points are those for which the defining
the associated vector field of the
function which is either its gradient
field or its min max gradient field
vanishes so are all these things are
always points desirable
absolutely not
absolutely not but
uh
if it so happens that we cannot even
find
these type of points then we're in big
trouble all right
so
[Music]
that's about all uh for the basic setup
and in terms of blanket assumptions as i
said uh we will be uh
mostly working with unconstrained
problems in terms of uh statements
just to avoid trivialities we will
assume that the problem always admits a
solution non empty critical set
and we will also assume uh licious
continuity and smoothness
for for the objective function
again these uh
these results are sorry these
assumptions can be tweaked and they can
be
fine-tuned to get stronger or
or weaker in some cases results
but these are very
comfortable assumptions to work with and
they simplify the presentation so that's
what i'm going to use throughout
okey doke so
in terms of algorithms which i i want to
discuss again a class of algorithms very
quickly before discussing the oracle to
address a manolos question
uh
first type of algorithm we'll consider
is simple gradient ascent so we're at
the given point we get we query an
oracle we get uh our uh we get our
gradient and then we take a step
another algorithm that we would like to
consider is the backward analog of this
of this uh of the of uh standard
gradient this of standard gradient
method namely proximal point where uh in
order to make an update you need to
solve uh an implicit fixed point
equation to calculate the gradient at
the point at which you would end up with
so this is implicit in general
non-implementable method
um
but also it's first order approximate
which is or rather i should say yeah
first order approximate depends on how
you count orders uh which is the extra
gradient algorithm where you start for a
point with a point you get a you make a
gradient query you
calculate a leading state then based on
this leading state you get a new
gradient and you transport this gradient
back to your original point and you take
your update all right
extra gradient optimistic gradient you
do the same thing it's only that instead
of calculating a gradient here you take
the gradient the last gradient that you
observe and you use this to do this
extra update
all right
and of course there is a bunch of other
algorithms that will fall
that
that are being used in practice and we
would also like to analyze with a sort
of unifying umbrella
such as for instance alternating
algorithms where
first one player updates then another
player updates and so players update
sequentially or uh if we go back to
the original paper on guns
and
we check out the specific instantiation
of gradient descent what was done there
is we have
what is known as a k1 update where one
player performs k updates for the other
players one
and uh again uh then the sky's the limit
i mean there's a huge literature on uh
on first of their algorithms
that have been developed to solve
minimax optimization problems uh from
jumbo pog uh step size scaling methods
methods with virus reduction and then
combinations of all the above you
basically take
a bunch of lego pieces you
you lay them on the floor depending on
what is the construct and what is the
specific problem that you want to solve
you combine your legos and you get
a new algorithm with potentially new
properties
so
now finally to answer manoli's question
and to provide the sort of unif unifying
umbrella of algorithms that we'd like to
study
these are all algorithms that fall
within the generalized robins monroe
template what does this mean uh it means
that uh all we take we will consider all
algorithms that can be written in this
general form where v of x n is the
gradient field at the state in question
u n is
some zero mean noise so so far this is
just stochastic gradient
but the novelty here is that we
also consider
an additional bias term a uh
an
extra term which might uh which is not
necessarily uh
zero mean uh it might not even be
stochastic uh all right and this bias
term uh is what measures is uh the
measure of difference so uh so to speak
of this of the generic robust minor
algorithm from the vanilla gradient
descent
so in the case of greater descent ascent
we have exactly this formulation with uh
with bias equal to zero
uh in the proximal point method we have
uh
again a generalized romans monroe
algorithm with the bias being the
implicit minus the explicit gradient
and uh in the extra gradient case we
have
again a robin's one row method with the
bias being the difference between the uh
between
the
leading staked gradient and the base
state gradient and so on so forth and uh
this
this method this template is actually
flexible enough to also analyze uh if
you want even zeroth order method like
single point stochastic approximation
methods and so on so forth
um
the uh
so far the only uh
when we
instantiate this
algorithm to
one of these uh to one of these cases we
will assume a stochastic first order
orbiting
which we'll discuss in the case of
explicit assumptions just to give you an
idea so far uh these stochastic first
order organ for the gradients will be
zero mean and we'll have bounded
variants
and we will discuss this again in the
in the sql and will only concern this
noise term
so
what
is the template with which we will
analyze this the important observation
and the starting point is that if we
just look at if we isolate
the gradient term
uh this can be written all these all
these algorithms can be written as a
as an explicit
euler discretization up to some
uh error now this error would be either
zero min or zero mean plus some bias
depending on the algorithm
but
if it is
small
then we would like to compare the
trajectories of the method to the
trajectories of an underlying mean
dynamical flow in continuous time all
right
and
the idea would be that if the step size
of the method is
small whatever that means uh
and the noise and the various errors are
suitably well behaved
then
the limit of the
uh
of the discrete time robinson algorithm
would be the same as the
long run limit of the underlying
dynamics
how to make this uh into a precise
definition
this is a uh this is where things start
getting technical
um in the uh there is a very um widely
used method uh called the holding method
the order differential replacement
method in stochastic approximation
which introduces the notion of an uh of
an apt an asymptotic suited trajectory
what is this
uh you take your uh you take your
sequence
uh and you introduce a virtual
continuous time variable which is based
on the method step sizes and you
introduce this linear interpolation of
your
methods
iterates all right now this linear
interpolation of course is just a curve
in continuous time and you say that this
uh curve in continuous time is an apt an
asymptotic pseudo trajectory of the
underlying flow when these are
relatively complicated condition holds
what does it tell you however if you uh
if we decipher it term by term it tells
you that if you compare
your position on the interpolated curve
relative to the position where you would
be if you had followed the flow
of the underlying mean dynamics starting
at the same point as the curve
and if you look at the maximum of these
differences
you take the starting point of the curve
to infinity well then this result is
zero
so
in
slightly
less convoluted terminology and this
tells you that if x of t if this if this
curve is an apt of the underlying mean
dynamics of the underlying flow then
this means that it tracks the flow the
entire flow not a particular not just
one trajectory of the flow but the
entire flow with arbitrary accuracy over
windows of arbitrary length
um
as the starting point goes to infinity
so this is an asymptotic result
all right so
i know that uh if you're not familiar
with this uh with this notion uh
then uh it can uh first of all
appear
convoluted artificial hard to check
everything
and all these all things all these
things are true
uh
what is uh very useful in this notion is
that there exists some very
uh
deep uh criteria
under which you can say when
a robins monroe algorithm
is an apt of the underlying flow
and then there is another set of
criteria which tell you
that which describe the behavior of apts
for a given flow
so by combining these two uh
these two types of results we will be
able to go from continuous time back to
discrete time now
um
yes
what is a t capital in the supreme or it
is a typo
no it is not tikka it is not a typo
this decap this big t this big t would
be what i would say here over a window
of arbitrary t of of arbitrary length so
this uh definition that i wrote here
should be interpreted in the sense that
this limit is zero for any window length
so just to
explain again you look at the maximum
difference actually i should
i should
draw a picture this will be much simpler
what happens is that you have
your flow
these are your flow lines and
this is
your care so what you do is you start at
a given point let's say
here x of t
and you compare two points you compare
where you are on the curve after time h
and where you would have been
if you had started on the flow and you
went forward for time h all right
this is
this is the distance
that you study
this is exactly the distance that you
see here
and the window length t
it tells you
that you want to look at the maximum
of this distance over a window of time
big t
all right
and if the maximum of this distance as
the starting point as the starting time
goes to infinity
goes to zero for every window length
then you say that this blue curve is an
asymptotic scooter trajectory of the red
flow
all right
so when i get it
one further question uh
so x t
how is it defined in terms of what is
the virtual could you explain the
virtual trajectory bullet like yes
yes yes yes yes yes yes let me explain
so first of all
that my process in general remember that
it is of the form x n plus 1 is equal to
x n minus gamma n
something all right
so i am viewing these gamma ns the step
sizes as alarm clocks
so gamma n is a stepping time so this
virtual time is just the total time that
has elapsed after n iterations of the
original algorithm all right
and what this virtual trajectory is
is the following
i take uh i take
my sequence x n here
x n
x n plus one
so on so forth and i interpolate
between linearly
between all these points
all right
this is my
function x of t
and i'm doing this scaling so that at
time tau n
my curve is at point x n
makes sense
yeah it makes sense so but for example
how do you do initial conditions like if
you want x of t to be something specific
you have to initialize your discrete
process your discrete sequence to
you know start there but also what if
this is just your x of x one x one is
where wherever you initialize your
algorithm
but if it's like extra gradient you have
to set x minus a half or something as
well
so
what i so
very good question uh
extra gradient optimistic all these they
have two initializations okay so
basically in order to start either extra
gradient or uh or um
or
optimistic grading you basically need
only an initial condition and an initial
leading gradient all right that is what
will start your your algorithm but this
for the definition of an apt is
irrelevant because what we're interested
in is we have some algorithm which has
somehow based on some initial conditions
generated a sequence xn
given the sequence xn we construct this
interpolated
virtual trajectory x of t
and we give the definition of what an
apt is based on uh on this interpolated
sequence
okay thanks
all right
so this is this is actually uh this
slide always
causes
cause expression because i realize it is
a very
a very delicate and a very weird concept
so if you have any more questions please
uh please feel free
and be assured that we will not
we will use the notion of what an apt is
in the sql but mostly as a black box but
if you have any more questions about
what it is i'll be happy to answer them
all right
um so
okay
so let's start uh
okay so i'm running out of time it's
okay
i'll manage
uh
now very uh very quickly as i was saying
uh the first question i would like to
answer is when is a sequence generated
by rob's monroe algorithm and apt
and here
we will have two types of condition the
first type of condition has to do with
uh
base type assumptions which concern f
and its behavior towards infinity
and these uh
these have to do with the primitives of
the problem the other type of conditions
now is when we really need to start
looking into the statistics of the noise
process and these are three types of
condition first that the bias goes to
zero with probability one uh that it is
summable when coupled with the step size
and also that the noise is square
summable when coupled with the steps
under these conditions which are
implicit hence the name implicit implied
here is what it implies we know that if
all these conditions hold then the
generated sequence is an apt with
probability one
the problem is that of course that these
conditions are implicit so they are not
verifiable
so in order to get uh an explicit uh
explicit conditions from this
uh
well this is where we need to start uh
using assumptions from the actual oracle
that is producing stochastic gradients
and our assumptions here are as i said
simply that the oracle uh is
zero mean and returns us uh
uh
gradients with finite variance
if we have this type of oracle and we
have any step size between one over n
and one over square root of n basically
which can be made
which can be relaxed but
it's fine for our purposes then we have
the same result namely that xn
any robins monroe algorithm gives rise
to an apt
of the mean dynamics so that's one part
of the equation the other part of the
equation will be to see what the uh
what type of convergence properties the
apt
how we can use these discrete
uh this this discrete continuous
comparison result
and
here
is when things become
quite complicated
in the minimization setting
we have
we can obtain a very simple very
straightforward description of these of
the long run limits of of apts precisely
because we have a gradient flow in
minimization problems all right
uh and by leveraging this this property
uh you can
uh
the
these were the most foundational uh
results of stochastic approximation
theory was that you can show that all
rob's vulnerable methods converge to the
critical set of the underlying objective
function and using it using the this is
this type of result you can also show
that this method avoids spurious uh or
saddle point as pure saddle points uh
first the p mantle showed this for
hyperbolic functions then uh worked by
ghetto showed this uh
for a second order for converges to
second order optimal points in the
stochastic regime then worked by lee and
authors by jason and authors in the
deterministic case etc etc
so
the basic question that i want to answer
in the five
minutes that remain is whether this
intuition carries over to
mean max optimization problems
specifically whether we have convergence
to unit or laterally stable critical
points and or whether we avoid spurious
non-equilibrium
sets
and
here
to dovetail with the previous talk
the problem of course is that in megamax
problems we don't have a potential
it is we no longer have a grading flow
and things can be arbitrarily
complicated so we need a different
notion of criticality and we need to
introduce a range of uh of definitions
of invariant sets
uh so uh
just to clarify an invite set is
environment for the mean dynamics
whenever it's image well remains the
same
it is attracting where when it attracts
nearby orbits and it is what we call
internally chain transitive or ict
when it is invariant and it contains no
proper attractors
why are these sets uh well
sets like that would be
could be limit cycles
or
heteroclinic networks like that these
are all ict sets
so they can be really quite complicated
but their importance lies in the
following base result
that
with probability one
any robins monroe algorithm will
converge to an ict set of the mean
dynamics
uh of course this this was the classical
result this relies on these implicit
conditions that uh are difficult to
verify uh there is an explicit barrier
there is an explicit variant of this
result that if we have this uh finite
second moment uh for the
variance of the oracle then with
probability one the sequence generated
by any robust monroe algorithm will
converge uh so and in particular with
from any of the algorithms that we
discussed will converge to an ict set of
the underlying mean dynamics
all right
good news bad news
good news is that
you can show that
these points whenever uh whenever you
have convergence you can never have
convergence to uh sort of an unstable uh
point or an unstable periodic point a
periodic orbit meaning uh you can never
have convergence
if to
to a point or to a periodic orbit which
has an unstable critical manner
this is in a sense the direct analog the
direct analog of the
sudden point avoidance result that we
have for uh for the minimization setting
um uh
modulo the fact of course that here in
the minimax setting we could have enviro
more much more complicated sets that we
would like to avoid like like periodic
orbits and the like
so
looking back
we have one result result that tells us
that
we
as in the
minimization case we have convergence to
ict sets
and in the minimization case case ict
sets and components of critical points
coincide
and we have avoidance of unstable
periodic orbits just as we have
avoidance of strict saddle points in the
minimization framework
so
is there a fundamental difference
between min and min max problems
well
the problem in these two statements is
not this one this is actually this is
actually the stronger one this is the
this is the good news of the uh of the
whole thing
uh and uh
the bad news is that ict sets could
actually be
spurious
attractors
so
i will jump forward
and then
if there are questions i will go back to
this
what i want to say
is that if we were to examine to go back
to the original
bilinear game almost by linear game that
we studied which has
a
this simple bi-linear uh
term plus
a very very an arbitrary small
perturbation
um
it is not easy it is not easy there is a
lot of uh
work needed here uh based
on computing a quantity called the
alexander polynomial of uh
associated to this to this objective
uh but what you can show is that uh
this objective function has
a critical point
uh at the origin
and
a stable limit cycle
and because the system is cleaner by
point carbon dixon
you know and because this point is
unstable you know that this
limit cycle is going to be
is going to be attracting almost all
almost all
initial conditions
what is the result
the result is that if you have and the
general result is that if you have
an attractor
then
any sequence generated by this entire
robust bond raw scheme of algorithms
will converge to this attractor with
arbitrarily high probability and of
course again there are two versions of
this result one for implicit type
conditions and one for explicit type
conditions which covers all of the
um all of the algorithms that we that we
saw
all right
and it is
these
these convergence to attractors uh
results that you can establish for the
entire gamut of
robin's manual algorithms that is
actually the bad news in the process why
because all these algorithms share the
same underlying mean dynamics
and because the mean dynamics exhibit as
furious attractor this shows you that
all these robins wonder algorithms they
have no choice they will all converge to
these spurious they will all be trapped
in this spurious uh in this purist limit
cycle no matter what you no matter what
you do you might try to introduce
more refined extra gradient or
optimistic uh or optimistic tweaks you
might introduce
uh
very finely tuned
step sizes or even adaptive step sizes
this doesn't matter because you have
this
mapping from
continuous to discrete time given by
apts
and because you can
determine the internal chained
transitive sets of the underlying mean
dynamics this cert this shows you that
whenever you have such an attractor ah
you will never be able to escape it with
any algorithm that falls in this
generalized robinson road template
so
just to conclude uh if you want
this is the
these are some of the key takeaways that
i wanted to stress with this uh with
this talk that uh first order uh robin's
monroe minmax method
you in the
non-monotone non-convex concave setting
you may have limit points that are
neither stable nor attractive
and also that by the bilinear games that
we uh love to study
may actually be very bad representative
case studies for the development of min
max algorithmic tools because uh at
least this
entire range of uh this very wide range
of
first order algorithms cannot avoid
spurious non-equilibrium sets with
positive probabilities
and
uh if we want to
do better
if we want to go beyond these
these traps then
we should probably bear in mind at least
this is uh this is my
my belief
that we need radically different
approaches if we are to hope to achieve
uh strong convergence results bit uh
beyond the uh convex concave setting
and of course all this
this is
perhaps deeply personal belief to be
discussed but
i think i'll stop here because i think
i've exceeded my welcome
so thank you panayoti
are there any questions in the room or
[Music]
zoom
let me start with one so uh i guess so
in my analysis talk we saw some dynamics
that actually
are guaranteed to converge to
uh
critical points
of some kind so i guess this must avoid
your theorem right i
i saw them too i want to uh i am very
very interested to pick uh to pick both
your brains uh about this uh what i what
i could tell for well first of all they
are second-order dynamics all right so
since they're second order because
you're uh pre-conditioning everything
with the with the hessian uh these do
not fall into uh the uh
the robinson draw first order framework
that this talk was about
now
uh
that being said uh i wasn't
super clear
in manola's presentation on the first
step where we uh
where we somehow use a line search to
find an optimum uh and things like that
what i would like to say uh for that is
that um two things first of all if we
have access to uh to an approximate
minimization oracle then all bets are
off okay because there are actually uh
results um
that uh
uh similar to the one you uh you uh that
manual is presented that tell you that
if you have an appropriate access to an
approximate minimization oracle uh then
you can
then you can establish convergence to
critical points
the second thing i wanted to say is that
um
um
actually let me let me stay here let me
stay here because the second thing will
be will take some time to explain so uh
this will derail the question so let me
let me stop there so
two elements first of all is the second
order secondly it needs access to uh to
minimize to a maximization oracle so
this is where the theories become
compatible
yeah so i guess
the initialization is not exactly access
to a minimization oracle is just
solving a lower dimensional problem of
the same sort
but i guess
it gets too technical so let's respond
that for now
so going back
going back now to the i will try to
focus in
hopefully simple problem strongly convex
strongly concave and i give you access
to a noise version of
your gradient
do we have any method that will converge
yes or no because from the discussion
here uh i will say this
is this is this is super this is a super
simple problem because you said strongly
strongly uh strongly contacts concave
right right right okay so
very nice ict set is the unique solution
of the problem everything will all these
algorithms will convert will choose
we'll convert another question now do we
have uh from the theory
of
robins monroe and bernaim
rates of convergence above
no
we do not uh the theory
this theory is deeply asymptotic in
nature
and
there is
there is a very
strong reason for this which is the
following
in a minimization in the minimization
framework framework or whenever we just
have uh
whenever we just have only critical
points that we want to converge and we
have no spurious attractor of the sort
then it is very easy to define a merit
function uh meaning um you know
as as in
as in yesterday's talk either the gap
function or the gradient norm squared or
what have you which uh when minimized
establishes convergence to a critical
point fine
here when you have uh when you have been
attracting a trapping limit cycle well
then there is no stationarity there
there is no vanishing gradient there
there is no gap function basically there
is no uh there is no standard merit
function that you can use to uh to
establish a conversion certificate and
say
accept possibly something very generic
like house of distance to to a set now
how's the distance to set is extremely
complicated
so you cannot use this but uh from uh
from countless construction uh you know
that every attractor admits a local
japanese function
very difficult to construct but for this
level for this japanese function it is
possible to um
to
[Music]
to establish race so to
sum up my answer to your question yes it
is possible to get rates
for a metric which is not
uh
very easy to certify
in uh
in general
which however i would have to say is
sort of the same problem that you have
with variational inequalities because
the gap function
that we all like to use in variational
inequalities this is not a this is not a
performance metric that we that we can
actually evaluate so if i just give you
a point x i cannot tell you what gap i
cannot calculate gap of x i might i may
have guarantees for gap of x but i
cannot calculate gap of x without
solving another variation
does this answer your question
all right so very nice talk and i really
like the this unifying theory of
different algorithms in the robbins
model framework i was just wondering
like
it seems to
to suggest that all these like different
algorithms have similar dynamics
but i think that the key difference
among these algorithms should be like
their ict set might be different right
but is this captured in in the in the
result here
this this is actually exact
thanks for the great question i uh i
couldn't have engineered this uh
dispersion uh
actually this is the um the
the the cracks of the matter
the ict set is not algorithm-dependent
it is flow dependent
so since all these algorithms are mapped
to the same flow are our apts of the
same flow
the only thing that counts is the ict
sets of the underlying flow
and it is for this reason that at least
generically in
a non-linear min max problems uh
all these algorithms have the same uh
have the same uh behavior
does this
does this
yeah sure yeah it's just a
because my
impression is always like different
algorithms right they should have
different dynamics and they should have
different ict sets some might have most
most spurious you know non-equilibrium
sets maybe some have larger right
somewhat smaller i feel like maybe the
reason here is because there was this
bias term
right and then you have this uh
unifying the assumption on this this
despised term like how it converts to
zero and that might have you know so
makes these algorithms
non-differentiable from each other
um
let me let me try and uh and give you
uh an answer first of all because i
at least i think i understand where
you're coming from because
we know that these algorithms if we
if we work on the deterministic case and
on a bilinear problem they do have
different behaviors so there is no
there's no way of going around this fact
okay for sure
uh so um
if i
would it be correct to interpret your
regression as so since this happens in
the thermistor regime how can you claim
that they have the same ict sets would
it be a correct interpretation right
yeah
okay so
great the uh this is a slide that i
didn't show
but
indeed
what happens is that uh in the bilinear
case
the the actual dynamics are uh or what
is called the pancreatic
what this means is that the uh sorry uh
what this means is that you have
basically a foliation of the of the
state space into this joint
non-isolated periodic orbits and
what happens in this case is that
all every individual of this periodic
orbit is japan of stable
none of these orbits is attracting
and so
as a consequence of this
every annulus containing the origin in
the standard min max game x y is an ict
set
so
in this in the bilinear case you have a
degenerate structure you have so many
the ict sets of the underlying flow are
completely degenerate so in that case
you lose predictive power
but there is uh there is a counter to
this which is known as the kubka smail
theorem which tells you that this type
of poincare recurrence this this type of
recurrent behavior
on the uh of that you observe in
bilinear games is actually
uh is a is actually meager in the bare
category sense meaning that in the
entire space of min max
min max problems uh only uh this
behavior occurs only
only on a meager set meaning on
accountable union of nowhere dense sets
so
this
this is why this is one of the reasons
that i'm saying that i believe that the
behavior the difference that we see
uh for different algorithms gradient
type or extra gradient type in
mo in merely monotone in bilinear game
games is actually
bad for build building intuition in the
beyond the monotone setting
thanks a lot
thank you so this sparked a lot of uh
interesting talk so thank you very much
in the interest of time let's postpone
further questions
uh thank you very much
thanks everyone
hi
also panayotis i believe is coming to
berkeley at some point so uh mid-march
excuse me
mid-march maybe march okay so
we'll have a chance to interact with him
uh when he comes
thank you
hi everyone